that's a long day yeah it
is that's it's hard to fill your days no
matter what I mean look at Ryan over
here don't ask him a question cuz he
can't talk but like you know you know he
he probably has days where he's just
bored off his ass and he's a lot younger
than we
are bastard son of a do you do you
uh look you're known a lot is well in
the film world not so much in the
theater world as being a like playing
great villains do you love playing
villains was there a time in your life
you're like I I don't want to play the
villain anymore I don't want to play the
bad guy I don't want to I want to play
you know this or did you how how how did
you work with that I don't
know what I kale what's the critic's
name from The New Yorker all I remember
is Canby kale k she called me in the in
the New Yorker she called me the prime
rter of the80s
the prime R meaning rotten characters
yeah yeah villains yeah Prime rter of
the 80s that's awesome I know it was
awesome well how could you yeah yeah but
the villains move the play along yes
they do they're the most interesting
active yeah sure they're the most
interesting yeah uh especially when
there's subtext and there's uh
development in the character and reasons
why the character is bad all that stuff
you know you used to play Lon of Luther
and you always told me and it just
resonated throughout the the run of the
show for me was
that you have good intentions you I'm
not you're like I'm not evil I I love my
son yeah cuz people you know the
villains they don't I mean nobody that
yeah they don't think they're old